[Music]
these I have to ask you we're talking
about your romantic life marriage dating
have you tried computer dating computer
dating yeah line dating yeah butor
dating is like you're going out with
actual computer oh you're so funny
please no Dorothy drive No I mean
sexually
give me a break I'm 77 years old tell me
of this computerized kids well it's
either that or the singles bars
yeah well have you tried this online
dating no I've never done it I have a
friend he did it me actually he met his
wife on one of those sites I asked him I
was like oh would you search because
kind of a weirdly romantic thing you
know he types in this phrase there's all
these like algorithms and stuff that
come together his woman's face comes up
he clicks it that becomes a woman he
spends the rest of his life with
ask my like what do you search and he
goes Jewish and my zip code that's how
no Wendy's a few weeks ago ladies in my
zip code then I got some nuggets
otherwise the exact same way
[Applause]
[Music]
you